The one piece manga just dropped an ABSOLUTE
BANGER because FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER we
saw the full devil fruit transformation of
one of the legendary Gorosei.
And let me tell you this was SHOCKING in more
ways than one because not only does Saint
Saturn appear to be some demon bull from Japanese
legend, but we also saw some mind-blowing
magical abilities that honestly I have no
logical explanation for.
But that doesn’t mean we won’t try to
die deep into speculation later on, but that’s
not all this chapter revealed because it appears
that Bonney and Saint Saturn have major beef
to settle because when she came face to face
with him she LOST HER MIND and straight up
stabbed the Gorosei in the chest.
Like damn.
She is not messing around.
On top of all that, Luffy and Kizaru continued
their epic brawl, with Luffy even busting
out some new Gear 5 techniques.
But even that is not enough to bring down
Kizaru because the admiral got away from Luffy
again and nearly wiped out the main Stella
Vegapunk.
And honestly, I’m starting to sweat a bit
about how this is going to go because when
Luffy ran out of time for Gear 5 at the end
of this chapter that now puts the straw hats
and the rest of the allies in a TERRIBLE SITUATION.
With Saint Saturn and Kizaru still ready to
fight, this could turn out WAY WORSE than
we ever thought possible.
Speaking of the always chill admiral though…
I mean, don’t have to tell you, but man,
Kizaru is just one of the most stylish characters
in the entire story.
The suit, the golden glasses.
The entire Mafia style that he has going.
I mean if you’re like me, you probably wished
you could have a pice of that drip cake here.
And luckily today’s Sponsor Holzkern, has
made this dream come true for both me AND
you.
Now you probably know of Holzkern’s products,
because I wear them in pretty much all of
my videos.
You might have seen this beautiful watch and
you DEFINITELY know this insane necklace,
that I just wear…like always.
And I think it speaks for the quality of a
sponsor when you actually love to use their
items on a daily basis.
And not only are they insanely stylish, Holzkern’s
entire concept also revolves around helping
the environment, using a lot of beautiful
natural stone and wood in their products which
in a really nice way makes you feel closer
and connected to nature.
Their watches are just insanely beautifully
crafted, but they also have accessories like
rings, bracelets, earrings and maybe most
importantly sunglasses, so you can actually
get some of Kizaru’s drip by getting your
own pair using the link in the description
below.
Which actually brings me back to the video,
where before we get to anything else WE HAVE
TO TALK ABOUT Saint Saturn and the chaos we
witnessed in this chapter.
Because I am still trying to wrap my brain
around what we just saw, but I’ll try my
best to explain everything we know and can
guess about Saint Saturn’s abilities.
First, we see this incredible magical circle
with a five pointed star suddenly appear in
the middle of the island, and then right after
this Saint Saturn makes his first moves on
the island.
Now before we get to man himself, we have
to discuss this diagram because of the MASSIVE
CLUES it can give us about Saturn and even
the other Gorosei.
First, we don’t actually know if Saturn
himself created this magic circle or if the
circle was somehow necessary for Saturn to
make his transformation, which we’ll discuss
in full detail in just a moment.
I mean the easy thing to say is that Saturn’s
powers made the circle appear, but I also
wonder if maybe someone like the world’s
secret ruler, Imu, created this circle and
that allowed Saturn to transform.
It isn’t that wildly impossible since back
in chapter 1085 when we first saw silhouettes
of the Gorosei’s transformation, Imu was
also present and using their mysterious powers
before the Gorosei all transformed.
However, just as important as who made the
circle is what it can tell us about Saturn’s
powers.
Now this circle and five-pointed star symbol
is called a pentagram or pentacle, and let
me tell you it is a massive rabbit hole of
religious and cult symbolism which I already
dove headfirst into so that you don’t have
to - you’re welcome - but interestingly
enough this symbol has many different meanings
that you may not be aware of.
Of course, recently pop culture has basically
associated an upside down five-pointed star
with things like devil-worship and the occult,
but if you go back further in history there
is a lot more to discover about this sacred
symbol.
For example, in some religious systems, the
five pointed star represents harmony with
nature and the universe.
And it was even used in the Christian church
to represent good deeds and charity.
But the most interesting connection, and the
one that makes the most sense for One Piece,
is the star’s association with five umm…
let’s call them elements.
Those being Earth, Air, Water, Spirit, and
Fire.
Now why is this important?
Well for one this magic circle and star appeared
along with an explosion of black lightning
and fire, which I’ll connect to Saint Saturn
more specifically in just a moment.
But first, before we even get to see the transformed
world noble we get this super creepy warning
that anyone below the rank of Rear Admiral
is FORBIDDEN from looking at Saint Saturn
and his transformation.
And when I first heard this I was thinking
“What?
That’s a super specific command.
Surely if someone looked they would just get
demoted or something, right?”
BUT NO!
WE GOT THIS !This poor dude just looked at
the man and his head literally exploded.
Like what???????
My jaw dropped.
I mean, if I can be honest this felt like
some kind of cursed energy technique from
JuJutsu Kaisen, not a devil fruit power from
One Piece.
Seriously though, this just brings up a ton
of questions.
Like was this truly an unbreakable spell caused
by the magic circle?
Or was it some power that Saint Saturn can
use based on the commands that he gives?
And what about the Straw Hats and other allies?
Will they be affected by this rule?
Because you might be able to argue that someone
like Usopp or Nami is probably weaker than
a Rear Admiral.
Man, please Oda no, don’t do that to me.
But it also makes me wonder why it is specifically
Read Admirals and above that aren’t affected.
Is it because they have some mastery of haki?
Or some other specific reason?
I don’t know, but that’s enough about
evil curses and magic diagrams, let’s get
to the man himself.
And wow, I was shocked when I saw his full
form.
That’s because when we first saw the silhouettes
in chapter 1085 he had horns, so I originally
thought he might have some sort of Minotaur-like
mythical zoan, but clearly not.
Instead, his appearance is very similar to
the Japanese yokai, Ushi-Oni, which is basically
a demon cow or bull.
So what do we know about these mythical creatures?
Well, they're super creepy, for one with their
spider-like lower bodies and bull horns.
Kinda reminds me of Black Maria from Kaido’s
crew, but other than that there is honestly
not a whole lot about these creatures.
Japanese mythology states that they were incredibly
vicious and would attack and eat humans anytime
they could.
And while they don’t appear to have any
special abilities, they usually lived near
water and would even sometimes work with other
yokai like these serpent women in order to
capture more prey.
And that’s about it from the mythology,
but there is one other super important detail
we simply must discuss.
So let’s jump back to the actual view we
get of Saturn because he also has this mysterious
flame-shaped pattern on his lower spider body,
which brings us back to the five elemental
abilities that might be connected to the five
pointed star.
Because like we said the star appeared with
a burst of fire, so it makes me wonder if
Saturn can also use fire-based abilities alongside
his spider-bull transformation.
Which would also make sense with the marines
head exploding, because out of all of those
elements, fire would seem the most likely
to cause that kind of damage.
So wow, on top of already having Kizaru and
his light abilities, the straw hats may now
also be dealing with a rampaging, fire-using,
spider bull.
Sheesh, I definitely would not want to be
on that island right now.
But on top of the fire, Saint Saturn has clearly
awakened his zoan devil fruit, as we see by
the cloud scarf.
This is the same indicator for awakened zoans
that we’ve seen with Luffy’sGear 5, as
well as the two secret agents from earlier
in the arc.
Now beyond his powers, the magical star also
appeared with the number five, which makes
me wonder if there is a ranking or order system
to the Gorosei.
And if that is the case, then it makes sense
for Saturn to be the fifth ranking.
But does that mean he is the weakest or the
most powerful?
Who knows at this point?
I’m just still trying to figure out what
happened to that poor dude’s head.
And I’d say that this is honestly the very
first time that I’m feeling actual, legit
danger for the straw hat crew in a long, long
time.
I mean this is just some weird stuff happening,
but what’s not weird is you subscribing
to the channel for more one piece content
just like this.
However, all that danger didn’t stop Bonney
from straight up stabbing Saint Saturn in
the chest at the end of the chapter because
of some memory she had about her father’s
transformation into a cyborg.
So clearly there is some major conflict brewing
between these two, but this scene also clearly
shows he can be damaged.
Although I wouldn’t be surprised AT ALL
if he just brushes off this attack like nothing
and even heals the damage in the very next
chapter.
Now, you might be thinking that’s all we
learned about the Gorosei from this chapter,
but let’s take all this that we learned
about Saturn and try to apply it to the other
Gorosei.
Because if we are sticking with this theme
of five elements - which of course could be
wrong, but it seems like a strong theory at
this point - then what abilities might the
other four have?
Well, just going off of the clearest images
we got from chapter 1085 we have some idea
of what the others’ zoan transformation
could look like.
And when we compare it to how they were standing
earlier in the chapter, we can say that Saint
Warcury on the far right looks like some kind
of animal with a large tusk or horn, which
could be an elephant or rhino type transformation.
And to me that fits pretty well with an earth
ability.
Right next to him is Saint Mars, who looks
like some sort of bird which goes perfectly
with an Air power.
Moving around we have the most human looking
transformation which is Saint Nasujurou.
And honestly I'm not too sure if he could
represent Water or Spirit, and the same could
be said for Saint Juu Peter who just looks
like a blob with a large open mouth.
So not exactly clear about these too, but
the most disappointing part is that we still
can’t really pin down what their actual
devil fruit transformations will be like.
I mean we already thought they would be mythical
zoans, and now we know they might all be based
on Japanese legends, but which ones exactly…
well it is still too hard to know, for now.
But with this first hint of the Gorosei’s
mind-bending powers, we finally know how the
World Government has stayed in power for centuries.
And if you want a complete breakdown of the
entire world government system as well as
ALL, and I mean ALL, of the incredible military
forces they command, you can watch this video
right here.